[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est sur le mile pierre
potier dans le quartier de moulins à
gif-sur-yvette
pour un marché de producteurs le second
qui a pour but de favoriser les produits
locaux en circuit court avec la présence
d'une petite vingtaine de producteurs
qui qui sont présents dans la même
localité le marché est organisé en
collaboration avec la mairie gifle et le
père
le marché en fait là pour but d'aider
l'association agora é pa ris à pied une
association étudiante qui vient en aide
aux étudiants précaires pour
l'université de paris saclay je leur
donne aujourd'hui mais déjà vendus dans
la boutique ne je crois que je faisais
pas assez donc
je me suis dit pourquoi pas faire d un
marché producteurs avec des producteurs
qui sont partants soit les 2/3 connais
une vingtaine de producteurs et les
bénéfices ont totalement reversés à
l'association
les producteurs sont à moins de 200 km
parce que sur le principe de la boutique
on arrive à voir aujourd'hui 80 % des
producteurs sur les cendres de la
présence en boutique à moins de 80 km
aujourd'hui on a du coup 17 producteurs
qui sont de la région ile-de-france
yvelines essonne principalement et pas
mettre dehors et loire également qu'il
ya un gros sourcier pour moi de deux
producteurs
ce marché se déroule de 9h30 à 18h avec
une animation à 12 heures et à 16 heures
au gal bertrand tarde centrale supélec
la bande à joe et il ya aussi un manège
éphémère écologique où les parents sont
invités à pédaler pour faire tourner le
manège
[Musique]
le pays a mis en place également une
exposition éphémère sur les bâtiments
vacants
[Musique]
c'est le deuxième marché en six mois
l'objectif peut réussir en faire deux
par an 1 pour la rentrée de septembre et
un pour le printemps
[Musique]